Good morning church. It's such an
honor to be with you guys here today. My name is Brandon for
those who you those of you who do not know me and I get to serve
as the boys Ministry associate and so I get to hang
out with all the students and in such a pleasure and
a delight and as I'm up here, I do want
to take a second to thank our students. Thank
all of the students in here for just
how easy and how fun. They make my job whether it
is going to Sky Zone and going crazy
or whether we are going to Saint Louis together.
Or even going the Saint Louis and doing
King of the Beach.
And playing stick for all
hours and playing nine square as well. I want
to thank you guys for making my job so easy and
so to the parents and all the leaders in
here who support us and and give and
do all these things. And so we really appreciate everything and
trusting us with your students.
And so I got to Henderson Hills in 2020. I
started off as an intern and pretty much
I was here and then I took my
time at UCO and I recently graduated back in 2022. And
so as I transitioned into this full-time
role, I figured okay. What is
something I can do to just you know, make my life more difficult.
And one thing I landed on was okay. I'll start I'll
start Seminary and before you check out and just
say okay, he's gonna have these fancy Seminary words
and on and on and on he goes that's not
it at all. I am far from the poster Seminary
students and you'll find out why in a
little bit but I started Seminary August 1st, and I
do Southern online and so they offer eight
week blocks and so a whole 16 weeks of information
is crammed down into eight weeks. It's great.
It's truly awesome. So I started in
August and it was great. The workload wasn't too
bad. I was taking Carmen nudics, which is basically just
the interpretation of the Bible and learning all these cool tricks.
Very simple simple stuff and first
eight weeks were awesome student Ministry was great. We
didn't have a lot going on in particular. I'm just
Wednesday nights and casually seeing students and caring for
them when we got the chance.
And I loved it truly.
And then we got a week off, which is great. I enjoyed the week off
and then I started
another eight weeks
and this day weeks was intro to Old Testament one
recovering Genesis through Esther and eight weeks
and the workload was truly unlike anything
I've seen before.
And on top of that student Ministry life is getting
busier and crazier. We're planning for United conferences. It
all really good stuff.
But I got busy.
And it got hard.
And so we're here.
And week eight of eight.
It's finals week.
Yeah tomorrow. Yeah to everything is due tomorrow.
Yes, and I didn't mention this
but I did so it schools in Kentucky which basically
means that everything is on East Coast
time. And so I'm already in our behind on everything I
do.
and so
it's been hard.
I've been tired.
It's been a hard semester Hard Eight Weeks.
and so
I'm up here during finals week getting ready
for this Sunday in the midst of Thanksgiving.
And as you can guess not everything is done. I still
have more work to do whenever this is over.
And some of you may be feeling that anxiety from your
seats.
You can you can see okay, he's in trouble. We've all
been there.
And you can see where I'm coming from.
And I want to ask you guys the question.
I wonder if anyone else in here.
Has felt that way.
I wonder if anyone else in here has been feeling just the pressure
and weight of Life recently.
with Thanksgiving around us
the pressure to make everything perfect.
And to put on a successful Thanksgiving for all your family. I wonder
if that weighed on your soul.
And as I get older I start to see that Thanksgiving is
actually a pretty hard holiday for a lot of people for a
lot of different reasons.
And I wonder if you've been wrestling with that same thing this past
weekend.
and if so
I want to invite you to join me.
In just this tiredness this sense of
fatigue.
And this isn't a Pity Club where we just feel bad for ourselves.
but this morning
I want us to all leave feeling refreshed.
I want us to all see the faithfulness of God.
I want to see how God speaks into our
lives.
To yell your Bibles. Go ahead and turn with me to Psalm 52.
Be towards the middle-ish of your Bible.
So, let's see what the Lord has for us today in Psalm 52.
To the choir master. I'm a skill
of David. When do AG the adamites came and told Saul
David has come to the house of amalek.
Why do you boast of evil Almighty man?
the steadfast love of God endures all the
day
your tongue plots destruction
like a sharp razor you worker of Deceit.
You love evil more than good.
And lying more than speaking what is right.
You love all words that devour.
Oh deceitful tongue.
But God will break you down forever.
He will snatch and tear you from your tents.
He will uproot you from the lands of the living.
The righteous shall see and fear.
and shall laugh at him saying
see the man who would not make God his Refuge but trusted
in the abundance of his riches and sought refuge
in his own destruction.
But I am like a green olive tree in the
house of God.
I trust in the steadfast love of God forever and ever.
I will thank you forever because you
have done it.
I will wait for your name for it is good in the
presence of The Godly. Let me
pray for us dear Lord. We thank you for this time.
And we thank you that you are good.
Lord we thank you that you are faithful.
God would you open our eyes this morning to help us truly? See
that your name we pray amen.
and so the beautiful thing about Psalms is
these Psalms all 150 of them. They come
out of real life. They weren't written in
isolation for us to just stick on the fridge
or something. But no these Psalms originated from
real life situations.
And Laura was very kind with this chapter of Psalms and we see a
title that helps us understand the context.
And so as we read Psalm 52, we can actually take a peek
behind the scenes of what's really going on in the life
of David.
And so which means we need to capitalize on this
context.
We need to see what sparked this writing.
And so you have a bookmark or you can put your finger we're gonna
pause right here in Psalm 52 and we're gonna turn back.
So first Samuel chapter 20, it'll be
a couple books over.
First Samuel chapter 20, we'll also have the verses on the screen as well.
And as you're turning there a quick quick backstory just so
you kind of know where we're jumping in. So Saul is
King at this time.
But David has also been anointed king. So, this
is Forrest David to live on the run because Saul has pretty
much just lost.
his mind
in first Samuel 20 verse 30 we can see what's going on
in Saul's head.
This is his mindset. This is Saul talking
to his son Jonathan.
The insults anger was kindled against Jonathan and
he said to him you son of a perverse rebellious
woman.
Do I not know that you have chosen the son of Jesse meaning
David to your own shame?
Into the shame of your mother's necklace.
For as long as the son of Jesse lives on the earth neither you
nor your kingdom shall be established.
Therefore send and bring him to me for he shall surely die.
As you can imagine David does not feel safe in his home anymore.
But if we keep reading through first Samuel Saul doesn't stop there with
these thoughts of Vengeance and Wrath.
It's also send spies to scope out where David might
be.
One of those spies is dog.
the atomite who appears in a title of Psalm
and so once David has been discovered.
Doak runs back to Saul to tell him
I don't know what Saul has promised these men, but
I can only imagine the reward would be great for capturing
David and securing Saul's Kingdom.
And if we put ourself in the shoes of doughag.
We can just imagine the excitement he had.
He's got a story itself. He's got something to say
everyone's wondering where David is and he found them he's
walking back in the saw.
chest puffed up ready to ride out
David
in the first Samuel 22
We see this.
This scene take place.
22 verse 6
Now saw heard that David was discovered.
And the man who were with him?
Saul was sitting yet give you
under the Tamaris tree
on the height with his spear in his hand
and all his servants were standing about him.
And so we see this scene a saw
with a spirit in his hand ready to kill someone.
His men surrounding him.
And we keep reading.
And Saul said to his servants who stood about him.
here now people have Benjamin
Well the son of Jesse give every one of you fields and
Vineyards.
Will he make you all commanders of thousands and
commanders of hundreds?
So Saul is now trying to bribe his men and entice
them. Hey David cannot give
you what I can give you I can give you everything you want.
to continue
then doe AG.
the adamite who stood by the Servants of Saul said
I saw this on to Jesse coming to Knob.
to amalek
the son of attitude and he inquired of
the Lord for him and gave him provisions and gave
him the sword of Goliath the philistine.
And so the text tells us what do I says?
But I mean do I just had to burst out with this
information about David?
and so once Saul knows
where David is he has to do something obviously.
So Saul summons the priests who helped hide David and
care for him.
And we see their dialogue a couple verses down picking up
in verse 13.
And Saul said to him.
Why have you conspired against me?
You and the son of Jesse.
And that you have given him bread and a sword
and have inquired of God for him.
That he has risen against me to lie in wait as
at this day.
in the king says
you shall surely die amalek.
You and all your father's house.
And the King said to the guard who stood about him.
Turn and kill the priests of the Lord.
Because their hand is also with David.
And they knew that he fled and did not disclose it
to me.
But the Servants of the king would not put out their hands to strike
the priests of the Lord.
And the King said the dog?
You turn instructive priests.
In dog datamite turned and struck
down the priests.
And he killed on that day 85 persons who were
the landed opod and sonob the City of priests he
put to the sword both man and woman child
and infants Ox donkey sheep.
He put to the sword.
We see this evil going on.
We see everything that David sees.
David is seeing these men chased after him.
David convinces these priests to help him to feed him
so he can live.
Now these priests are dead.
David has seen how King Saul has lost his mind.
David sees all this evil.
around him
and even though Saul is in direct opposition
to the Lord.
By attacking his anointed David.
Enforcing David to live on the Run.
How does David respond?
If we go back to Psalm 52.
We see his response.
The first four verses David is asking
the question. Why do you boast of evil?
David Sees at the tongue of doughag has potted all
this destruction.
David sees and understands that these men love evil
more than they love the Lord.
They love with salt can offer them.
More than doing what is right.
David knows that Saul's words are seeking to devour him.
the most importantly
David knows
the God will be faithful.
in the midst of evil
God will be faithful in the midst of
evil.
And so we've already tried to put ourselves in issue of shoes of Doak, but
if we put ourselves in the shoes of David.
David is living on the Run.
He's constantly looking over your shoulder. He doesn't know who he can trust.
84 people just died because of
him in a simple interaction.
this emotional
spiritual toil had
to be heavy
it had the way on his soul.
And remember David was the anointed king at this point. So this is what his life
was looking like.
but remember
David is calling the people to look to God's faithfulness
in the midst of evil.
through everything that transpired and first Samuel
David is still telling the people. Hey.
evil will not conquer
evil will not stop who God is
and we feel this.
We see it.
the holiday season
we feel the pain.
We see the hurt.
It is hard to think. How is God gonna be
faithful through this?
How is God going to redeem this situation?
and so
it's easy to say God will be faithful in the midst
of evil.
But do we believe this?
Do we believe these words?
And so if you reflect on your own life and ask these questions.
When you see all the pain in Brokenness around
you.
You trust that God will work things
out.
Are you seeking to find your own solution?
in your own healing
in your own way.
Do you trust that the steadfast love of God will endure
forever?
Or do you find yourself throwing in the towel?
Because life is just gotten too hard.
And I don't think we should compare situations. But if
we look back at David's life later when we
learned that he was actually in the position to
kill Saul a couple of times.
Which means all his problems
could have went away.
This means he could have finally found rest.
He could have went home.
But David knew that would have been in direct opposition.
to the Lord
That was not what the Lord had for.
David chose to continue to trust in the steadfast love.
of God
even through the midst of evil.
He continued to find his Refuge instead of
looking to his own plans or his
own remedies.
And I get it. It's not easy.
And it's true that I don't know all of your stories in here.
I mean, I know the situation that you're currently walking through.
But back in Psalm 52, we can see the confidence that
David had in verses 5 through 7.
We see that God will be faithful
to judge.
God will be faithful to judge.
Listen again to what it says in Psalm 52 verses 5
and 7.
But God will break you down forever.
He will snatch and tear you from your tents.
He will uproot you from the land of the living.
The righteous shall see and fear.
and shall laugh at him saying
see the man who would not make God his Refuge.
But trusted in the abundance of his riches and sought
refuge in his own destruction.
We can see the reason David had this confidence.
Is because he knew that God would
write every single wrong.
He knew that God would judge the evil of this world.
This isn't a new theme in the Bible.
David would have grown up hearing these stories about how God rescued his
people.
from pharaoh
and how he brought judgments to Pharaoh because of the evil that
was transpiring there.
We see what happens when we don't make God our refuge.
We see what happens when we think that our abundance of
riches will lead us somewhere.
The only place that will lead us is destruction.
And I believe this section actually serves two different purposes.
one of the ways it speaks to us is this
David is speaking to his fellow believers.
And he wants to encourage them.
He wants them to remain obedient despite the
circumstances.
He knows that God sees this evil.
And will judge this evil he wants them to see that.
We know that Vengeance Belongs to the Lord.
And we can rest and have peace through the Brokenness all around
us.
The based on the context the situation
David's in I believe it serves another purpose as
well.
Have you taken notes or anything? I just I want you guys to pause
and just listen to this.
The other purpose is Tech serves.
Is that God will judge all unrighteousness?
God is faithful faithful to judge the evil around us.
And if we're honest with ourselves.
We have to understand that we all stand guilty before the Lord.
And God is not in the business of sleeping sins under
the rug or looking the other way.
If God is faithful to judge evil.
Then we have to understand that we are all evil.
We are all broken.
All of our sins will be judged.
We see the actions of the Mighty Man and the first four verses and
we can recall times where we have sought to devour
or have been deceitful or boasted an
evil.
And if you think that you're good, and that's not
me.
First John tells us that if we say we have
no sin.
We deceive ourselves.
And the truth is not in US.
And if we flip the page in our Bible and take a peek at Psalm
53, it says that they have all Fallen.
Together they have become corrupt. There is none who does
good not even one.
And Paul picks up the same exact theme in Romans
when he saw into both Jews and Gentiles how
they have all fallen short of the glory of God.
all condemned all stand guilty
and so yes, it is awesome that God will judge the
evil of this world and he'll be faithful to do that.
But we're all guilty.
We all have evil in US.
Do you understand that?
Do you understand that we all fall short?
And so I read early in first John chapter 1 just just verse
8, but if you keep reading in verse 9, we'll
see the greatest news that we can ever hear.
If we confess our sins.
He is faithful and just to forgive us our sins.
And to cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
If we admit that we have sin and we deserve the fullness
of God's Wrath.
Then it says God.
Will forgive us.
and cleanse us
But you're like, okay. You just said that God doesn't sleep sense of the rug. How
does how does this process even work?
You're right. God does not sweep our sins under
the rug.
Someone still has to pay for all that evil.
And punishment that was due to us.
Was put on Jesus.
We learned that Jesus was the propitiation for our sins,
which is a fancy word of just saying that Jesus satisfied the
wrath of God.
On our behalf.
Not only did he satisfy the wrath of God, but he reconciled us to
God.
And so God is faithful to judge the evil of the
world.
And put it on Jesus.
for us
and so if you've never heard of the name Jesus or have just
never truly put your faith in Jesus. I want
to take this moment to tell you.
Do it.
Put your faith in Jesus.
Jesus was the god man who
came down.
Lived a life that we could never live.
A perfect life with no sin.
And he died to death that we all deserve.
That is who Jesus is Jesus is
the one who satisfied God's Wrath.
for you
So put your faith in Jesus.
Because Believers in the room.
We can have confidence that the wrath of God was satisfied on Jesus.
but if you've never put your faith in Jesus
God is going to judge that in the future.
So our hope is in the fact that God sees the Brokenness.
And the evil of the world and will judge it.
The pain everything we see around us.
God will make right.
And that's the confidence that we have.
Our father has not forgotten about us. So be encouraged
by what David says in this song.
But once again if you have never put your faith in Jesus.
This Psalm may serve as a warning.
And I'm not trying to scare anyone in here. I'm not
trying to be anyone up.
I just want to show you the necessity of the cross.
How we all need to put our faith in Jesus?
Thanks be to God that he's faithful to judge all the wrong in the
world.
Thanks be to God that he has saved us through the
blood of Jesus.
So we see this confidence that David has.
But how are we to do this? How is David able to stand firm and
rest in this midst of evil?
Listen to what? He says as we close out our texts and verses 8 and
9.
But I am like a green olive tree in the
house of God.
I trust in the steadfast love of God.
forever and ever
I will. Thank you forever.
Because you have done it.
I will wait for your name.
for it is good in the presence of
The Godly
David tells us that God will be faithful.
to save
God will be faithful.
now for those in here who have been keeping up with the NFL for
the last I don't know five to
six years. You understand that there has been
one team that has been dominant behind my
Pittsburgh Steelers come home for 12 anyone.
Uh, there's been one thing that's been super dominant.
Throughout these last this last stretch.
And it pains me to say the team's name, so I'm not but I
just know I'm referring to that team that plays in Missouri
their colors kind of remind you of
McDonald's.
The quarterback's name is Patrick. You guys know I'm talking about the Chiefs.
Yeah, I'm talking about the Chiefs.
Yeah.
Well the unique thing about this team.
Is that over the years the quarterback has instilled so
much peace into this fan base.
No matter what the score is or how much time is left.
Well, I'm unless it's like a blowout.
That if the game is in Striking Distance if
they can win it by a touchdown know how to no matter how
much time is left.
They can do it.
And so now I'm talking to Chiefs fans and I'm like, hey, like, hey,
the game was gonna really close there. You guys had like 40 seconds
left two timeouts. How are you feeling? Were
you nervous? And they look at me like I'm crazy. They're like,
you're not know who our quarterback is. We have Patrick Mahomes.
Obviously, he's gonna drive down.
He's gonna win the game.
These Chiefs fans have so much peace now.
And so now look at our text.
David tells us he is like a green olive
tree.
David is telling us that he is firmly rooted.
And who is God is?
Why?
Because this God will be faithful to save.
It's a deliver him.
That's the confidence that David leaves us with and David doesn't
just leave us with that confidence and says hey figure it out.
Figure out how to be a tree.
No, he actually walks us through some steps that he
takes and that he practices.
To be faithful to God as God is faithful to
him.
We see David makes God his refuge. And
this is the word that I've mentioned and David has
mentioned.
But we see three things that David does that we can practice today.
Well, everyone else is trusting in their own resources and their own
remedies.
He wants the people of God to do these three things.
First David puts his trust in the Lord. He says
I trust and it's that fast love of God.
We can wear ourselves out in this dream trying to
figure out every solution and every situation that we're
in.
And trying to figure out how things are going to work out.
And taking matters into our own hands.
But David chooses to trust in God.
So we need to all look around and ask ourselves.
What areas in our lives are we not trusting the
Lord?
Is the one who gave his son for you not worthy
of your trust.
The second way David shows us how we can make God our refuge.
Is by thanking him?
Why should we thank him.
When we look around we just see Brokenness and
pain what is there to be thankful for?
We should thank him for the faithfulness that he has shown us.
We should thank him because he saved us from judgment.
If we look in Psalm 52, we see
this really cool thing. We see a bookend of
50 song 52 verse 1 opens up with a faithfulness
of God.
And it closes talking about the faithfulness of God. So what
he wants us to see is the faithfulness
of God, and so that's what we should be thankful for.
That God has saved us
and God is faithful and God did send his
son to die on the cross for our sins. That's why we
should thank him.
The Third Way that David shows how we can make
God our refuge is by waiting on him.
And this is an idly just standing by and waiting for
God to return.
And there are more ways but to wait on God,
but in Psalm 52.
He shows us.
He waits in the presence of The Godly.
And so what that means is we should wait together for
the return of our King.
by encouraging one another
and pushing each other towards the cross.
when life gets hard as it often does
we wait by reminding each other that God will be
faithful and God is faithful today.
when fatigue starts to set in
and you're feeling the weight of everything.
We remind each other as Believers. Hey, God hasn't forgotten
about us.
We we tell each other. Hey, look what God has done at
the cross.
And we look forward to the day of God
coming back.
And so encourage one another as David is
encouraging us.
about the faithfulness of God
God will be faithful in the midst of evil.
God will be faithful to judge.
And God will be faithful to save and to deliver us.